i feel really good about that dance that
just went i really do i really do
yeah i was like this is not happening
right now yesterday halfway through i
was a little nervous about the dance and
then just to come in and see what i just
saw through that window i'm i'm
very very excited yeah well i want to
say thank you for all the feedback
you've given kaya i mean she is like on
cloud nine but i know this is gonna be
hard for you making a decision it's
terrible it's gotta be stressful for you
guys too exactly but it's fun that you
are like just
getting out of them what
they are and helping them see who that
is because most people want to change
you you know i want to figure out who
they are you know like tiny tea
understands who she is and who she is as
an artist and i think it's really cool i
want to see them evolve and i want to
make costumes and wardrobe for them i
want the choreography to be for them as
who they are as individuals and that's
why we can't have two that are alike
and can they and kyle look alike
is that nerve-racking because jess
doesn't want
two people to look alike or be alike or
i think it is very nerve-wracking
because
i mean charity most likely they won't
cast two girls that look so similar
you know if you see an outfit or you
know like just style it differently
don't dress them exactly the same
you have to like
make it your own you're saying kaya
copies kinley
[Music]
no i'm just saying they look alike i
don't really feel like they look alike
except that they're both blonde and at
this point they're the two blondes left
i was one of the moms saying the twins i
would have to ask leah when i saw kyle i
was like now that's not kindly right it
was confusing at the auditions i do
think that's a detriment if you're
trying to be in a pop group
[Music]